i think that what we're seeing right now
is with respect to marriage
in a conventional sense is we're seeing
a fundamental reimagining of
the relationship between men and women
as a result of bringing women
into like say the workforce or making
them putting them into
a position of social power that we have
after
the uh sexual revolution so right now
we're looking at things like you know
poly relationships or we're looking at
you know quote-unquote equal
partnerships or
any egalitarian kind of ideal in in
relationships
which simply doesn't work because and we
can see that it doesn't work because now
here we are in the 21st century and we
have access to the data
that shows us that when a woman gets a
you know
an increase in pay or she gets a you
know promotion at work that precipitates
divorce
why well because innately speaking that
woman wants a guy who is more valuable
who is taller stronger more protective
of
the three p's provisioning protection
and parental investment
and if that guy cannot provide if that
guy cannot make as much money and that's
how we
that's the only metric that women really
have right now if that guy's not making
that much money
he's economically unattractive she
doesn't want to marry that guy and she
doesn't want to pair with
that guy because on an evolutionary
level
that makes her feel insecure right now
he's dead weight
he's somebody that he's another child
that she has to be responsible for
in the family to some degree whether
he's you know whether he's making a lot
of money or is not
uh he's making less than she is and so
therefore um
she is uh she's responsible for another
you know for his security
whereas you know from an evolutionary
perspective it should be the other way
around
where the guys so so convincing women
to like when when rich was saying you
know well we have to or rich and aaron
and everybody else saying you know we
got to find some way to sort of convince
women that that that shouldn't be the
case it's like saying
it's like saying men should be attracted
to fat chicks right right
saying that like it's it's like saying
something that's fundamentally it goes
against our innate nature
that's never going to happen with women
but what we've done is we've given women
the option to say okay you can you can
be in control of your own security you
can have all the benefits of sort of
this new order way of thinking
but you have you're still based in your
old order
innate biological needs for these guys
to be
who they are and what they ought to be
so what you what you see i think
one of the things that's sort of like a
rude awakening i think for most guys
right now is
when they saw those at the um the data
sets
for um women finding men economically
unattractive
they also asked well what would make a
man economically attractive and they
found that
the man had to make at least as much
data as they did plus
58 more that made a guy economically
attractive that's that put him
up into at least the quote-unquote you
know high-value man
14 when i did the numbers 14 of men
yes yes and so like you said the eye of
the needle kind of thing
and i think the the rude awakening is
this is that most men
approach love from an idealistic
perspective we think that love should
matter just for the sake of love right
because we tend to be idealists we tend
to look
out at the world instead of in at
ourselves which is really where women
start to look right they're more
interested in people and men tend to be
more interested in things
right as a result of that when we talk
about like how women
don't want to get with a guy who's
economically unattractive what that does
is it exposes the game women love
opportunistically and women are men love
idealistically how do we know that well
we can see that women don't want to
marry guys who don't make more enough
money don't make the kind of money that
they
do you give women enough money and you
give them enough financial like we're
i'm i'm looking at the stats right here
this is from uber faxes worldwide
females earn
18 trillion dollars but they spend 28
trillion dollars
that to me sounds a lot like opportunism
right there
um the other stat was this is uh you
know american women hold two-thirds of
student debt
so when you look at things like this
it's like yeah women want to find either
a guy that's going to help them pay that
debt or they're going to vote for the
guy who's going to say yeah we're going
to absolve all of your student debt
and put you in the presidency because
that's that was part of your your
presidential platform was to get us out
of debt
so to me that sounds a lot like
opportunism right there
so when we're looking at those things
it's sort of
is a rude awakening for guys who want to
believe that their their sort of
you know their their love ideal is based
on i love you just as much as you love
me it's like well
women and men are approaching that in
marriage approaching love approaching
solving their reproductive problems and
everything else from different
perspectives
and we can see that in black and white
now that we have access to the internet
we have access to all of this
this stuff and so and then finally is
this is that i think that in the future
we're starting to see this
you know polyamory we're starting to see
you know
really polygamy is what it is and this
is an old school
uh roycey quote which is you know women
would rather share a high value alpha
than be saddled with a faithful beta
loser
and so what's happening right now is is
the hive the really super high value
guys are they're going to be the ones
who are going to be the cats who are
going to end up
out breeding the dads because those dads
are not as
they're they might be raising the
children of the guys that women want to
get with and want to have sex with and
want to reproduce with
but those other guys as long as they are
beta males who are
economically unattractive and in other
ways unattractive as
as rich was saying before it's like
they're not on their game they're not on
their
they're not trying to become the best
you know man that they can
they can possibly be if they don't even
just check out of the game
you know entirely what happens then is
we have a society that has to adjust for
that
so right now when when we talk about we
when we make single dads or step dads
superheroes we're basically saying you
know give up your
your any any claim you have to your own
paternity and that's okay
and women will say you know a real man
is a guy who steps up and takes over
even if the kid's not his when we start
popularizing narratives like that it's
as a result
of trying to change over to a new form
of relationship and that's what i think
is going to end up replacing
modern conventional marriage right now
that means a lower population
and what they're trying to do is they're
trying to invent these new categories of
like
marriages and relations like society
lies to women as much as it does to men
right i mean like
one of the more common ones is you start
to see a lot of these shows
and like video clips of these uh
career-driven women with the
stay-at-home father and then they
portray
you know the family unit as a modern
family marriage it's a modern family
it's very successful everybody's happy
except for when you look at the guy
he's a brow beaten plow horse you know
that they're not banging
maybe they have like transactional sex
once every three months or something
like that
and you can see it in her face she's
not happily married to this guy she does
not look up to him
there's no way that she ever looks up to
a guy like that the clock is ticking
down to the end of that relationship at
some point
but again women will consume these
narratives hook line and snicker yeah i
can go you know climb the corporate
ladder go feminism
women are equal to men blah blah blah
and they go and fabricate
these new families which don't last
you know they don't serve the children
properly they serve as hell don't serve
the
man and woman properly i i responded to
a guy i forget what what conversation
this was from but somebody had said
something about how or maybe i was doing
a breakdown video and somebody had said
something about how men should have the
opportunity to be stay-at-home dads if
they want to
and that that should be some sort of
ennobling
i blame mr mom wasn't that a movie in
the 80s michael keaton
yeah as if that should be some sort of
that's when it started yeah and like
that there's like this large demographic
of guys who are just pining over the
fact that they can't be like
stay-at-home moms like
like you know like a mom right like the
mr mom narrative and i was like there
are literally no guys that want to do
that there's
i mean and if there are it is such a
minuscule
percentage of guys that really want to
do something like that and it's not
because they're and it's not
because they're not
you know evolved males or anything like
that it's because that goes against
their innate biological imperatives is
what it is
you know most and you know what's
interesting to me is like
even even in in light of human males
investment in their own offspring it's
very rare in the animal kingdom for men
or for excuse me for for male animal
male mammals at least to be invested in
the in the upbringing of their own
offspring it's usually left to
the females to do something like that
and men are actually more invested even
as much as they can be right now
but when we see how marriage is a an
all downside contract for guys that's by
design that's but that's
that we're we're there right now because
we're trying to figure out how we're
going to
allow women to maintain this old order
ideal where they want to have the best
of the best
they still have to have they're still
you know their mating strategy is still
hypergamy they're still interested in
quality
but yet the the new order benefits
which is you can go and get your go get
your degree and go get become a doctor
and go get your you know
you're going to be lonely those are
going to be the the results of that are
going to be
in the future in 2030 the likelihood of
you being
a prime working age woman who is single
at no children and unmarried are
high are much more likely as a result of
that
so whereas we're trying to tell women
that they don't have these these
consequences aren't going to be
affecting them when in fact they are and
then when they get to that point then
that's a bridge that they'll cross when
they get to that point
but in the meantime we have to find some
way to convince them as rich was saying
here before
whether it's through popular media or
through pop culture through
to television shows or stories or
whatever the popular narrative is
is that this is the new way that we're
doing things and
we're still that new way is conflicting
with the old order innate biological
evolutionary
imperatives of human beings that's just
how the machine works that's just how we
evolved
so there's that
you